معنا من تلبيب مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
هو معنا وكنت قد سالتك الياس عن الاصداء
للتطورات
الاخيره للفيديوهات التي نشرت وكذلك
لزياره اوستن تفضل
الياس ليلى اولا ربما نتطرق الى شريط
الفيديو الذي بثه القسام عن المحتجزين او
الاسرى الاسرائيليين الثلاثه اي الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي تطرق مباشره الى هذا
الشريط ووصفه بانه محاوله لمحاوله ارهابيه
نفسيه ضد عائلات المحتجزين واشار الى ان
اسرائيل تفعل كل شيء من اجل اطلاق سراحي
جميع الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في
داخل قطاع غزه احد افراد اسره احد ال
المحتجزين وهو ليور رودا ف اشار الى الفرح
الغامر بعد نشر هذا الشريط الذي يظهر
والده بانه ما زال على قيد ال الحياه
ويتحدث عن المشاعر الجياشه ل احتمال
اللقاء مستقبلا هذا هذا ال هذه الاشرطه
ليلى تثير كثيرا من الغضب في اوساط عائلات
المحتجزين الاسرائيليين على اعتبار انهم
يقولون بان هؤلاء المحتجزين ربما يموتون
في الاسر ما لم تتحرك اسرائيل سريعا من
اجل انقاذ حياتهم وال والعمل على الافراج
عليهم ونحن نرى انه في الايام الاخيره
هنالك تصعيد كبير للحراك الشعبي في اوساط
عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين في داخل
اسرائيل من اجل الضغط على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وعلى مجلس الحرب من اجل العمل
عمل كل شيء من اجل الافراج عنهم لا سما
بعد مقتل ثلاثه من المحتجزين برصاص جنود
الجيش الاسرائيلي نهايه الاسبوع ال
المنصرم وما من شك في ان هذه الاشرطه تؤثر
نفسيا جدا على عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين
وتدفعهم في المقابل لتشكيل ضغط كبير وقوي
على الحكومه الاسرائيليه وعلى مجلس الحرب
وبالتالي هذا الموضوع كان ايضا ضمن الامور
التي تطرق اليها وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لويد اوستن حين قال بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تقف الى جانب اسرائيل في تحقيق
هدفها باستعاده جميع المحتجزين
الاسرائيليين وما قاله ايضا وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي في هذا السياق عندما قال انه
عندما تتحدث الاداره الامريكيه عن تقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه والطبيه لقطاع غزه
عليها وعلى العالم ان ياخذوا بعين
الاعتبار ان هنالك
129 اسيرا اسرائيليا محتجزين في داخل قطاع
غزه لكن ليلى الاهم في اقوال اوستن هذه
الليله هو ما قاله على الملا امام الاعلام
الاسرائيلي والدولي بانه لم ياتي لاملاء
جدول زمني على اسرائيل فيما يتعلق
باستمرار العمليه العسكريه وهو قال هذا
على الملا امام الصحافه وكانه اراد الا
يبرز وجود خلافات ما بين واشنطن وتل ابيب
فيما تتعلق بالجدول الزمني او السقف
الزمني لاننا نعرف انه ربما في الجلسات
المغلقه وفي اللقاءات الثنائيه التي حصلت
الموضوع الجدول الزمني والسقف الزمني جرى
التداول فيه وجرى الحديث عنه وخير دليل
على ذلك هو ما قاله وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي في زيارته الاخيره بانه ليس امام
اسرائيل اشهر في اطار العمليه العسكريه
انما ربما اسابيع لكن اوستين اراد ان يبرز
هذا الخلاف على الملا امام الصحفيين وما
يدلل على ان هنالك جدول زمني جاء هذه
المره ليس من الضيف الامريكي بل من وزير
الدفاع يوف جرانت عندما تحدث عن مراحل
معينه وتطورات مرحليه ستكون على العمليه
العسكريه بمعنى انه لم ينطق كلمه الجدول
الزمني لكنه تحدث عن مراحل زمنيه في عمليه
القتال توسيع نم القتال في المنطقه
الجنوبيه مقابره ربما مع تخفيفها في
المنطقه الشماليه والوصول الى قاده حماس
كما قال الواضح ليلى فقط في عجاله ان
اسرائيل الان امام مرحله جديده ربما تتمثل
في ثلاثه مراحل اولا عمليه عسكريه ربما
تكون متواصله وكبيره في المنطقه الجنوبيه
عمليه تمشيط في مناطقه معينه عمليات
عسكريه خفيفه وربما محاولات لاعاده بعض
السكان الفلسطين الى المناطق التي انتهى
فيها القتال وهذا ما المح اليه جلان في
حديث هذه الليله وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا في
سياق ما الذي تريده اسرائيل ايضا بعد
الحرب وهو سؤال يطرحه الامريكيون على
الاسرائيليين في كل لقاء يجمعهما تلخيص
جميل شكرا جزيلا لك الياس كرام من تل ابيب
شكرا